Ten's new Mouse has people pissed why
you have to be mad so ten just announced
his own Mouse this isn't another collab
like his Starlight Pro from last year
this time he's handpicking the shape and
specs himself I've been working on this
for quite a while now as I've always
wanted to pray my little perpect mouse
sounds cool right well pre-orders went
live and people aren't exactly happy
he's asking for
$190 us but hasn't shown anyone the
shape which is kind of crucial you're
telling me you want people to drop $200
on something that they have never seen
in this economy in this economy after
getting memd into Oblivion tens has
issued an apology and shared some early
images of what the mouse might look like
while freezing all pre-orders unbox the
tens Mouse I got you here let me just
pull it out there we go this is really
nice I like it a lot actually